so I get asked all the time hey do I  need to like grow my social media if I'm  selling social media services do I need  to be super jacked if I'm selling weight  loss or Fitness in terms of like do I  need to have walk the walk Etc the  answer is you should know how to get  there I ended up selling my gyms before  I ended up helping a lot of gym owners  grow their businesses the fact that I  didn't have the gyms at the time in no  way questioned my authority and my  ability to help them do it because what  you need to articulate is not have I  done it but have I taken people just  like you where you want to go and how  many times have I done that and if you  can articulate that the prospect then it  doesn't matter whether you have a  six-pack or you're just in medium shapes  at the end of the day if you've taken  100 people who look just like them to  where they want to go you're credit  worthy and more credit worthy than just  some guy with a six pack